STILL A GOOD NUMBER, THOUGH.
>> Harris: THAT’S AN EXCELLENT
POINT.
>> Dr. Nesheiwat: WE JUST WANT
TO SEE CONTINUOUS --
>> Harris: WELL, WE’LL MOVE TO
THIS.
THE NEW QUESTIONS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S RELATIONSHIP
NOW WITH THE TOP DISEASE EXPERT,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
THAT MEMBER OF THE TASK FORCE
WHO WE SEE WITH THE PRESIDENT
MOST DAYS.
THIS IS COMING AFTER THE
PRESIDENT RETWEETED A POST THAT
WAS CRITICAL OF DR. FAUCI, AND
CALLED FOR HIS FIRING.
THAT COMING SHORTLY AFTER THE
DOCTOR SAID THIS ABOUT WHETHER
THE UNITED STATES COULD HAVE
ACTED SOONER IN RESPONSE TO THE
SPREAD OF COVID-19.
WATCH.
>> I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY, YOU COULD
LOGICALLY SAY THAT IF YOU HAD A
PROCESS THAT WAS ONGOING AND YOU
STARTED MITIGATION EARLIER, YOU
COULD HAVE SAVED LIVES.
OBVIOUSLY, NO ONE IS GOING TO
DENY THAT.
BUT WHAT GOES INTO THOSE KINDS
OF DECISIONS IS COMPLICATED.
IF WE HAD IT RIGHT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, SHUT EVERYTHING DOWN,
IT MAY HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
BUT THERE WAS A LOT OF PUSHBACK
ABOUT SHUTTING THINGS DOWN BACK
THEN.
>> Harris: DR. FAUCI HAS RUN
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
ALLERGY AND INFECTIOUS DISEASES
FOR MORE THAN THREE DECADES, AND
THREW SIX ADMINISTRATIONS, JUST
TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE
ON HIS BACKGROUND.
MARIE, WHAT IS THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF WHAT WE WATCHED PLAY OUT THIS
WEEKEND ON THIS MATTER?
>> Marie: DR. FAUCI HAS,
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE CRISIS,
BEEN A VOICE OF SCIENTIFIC
REASON, OF SCIENTIFIC FACTS.
I THINK THAT’S WHAT YOU SEE HIM
GET SO MUCH WIDESPREAD ACCLAIM
FROM BOTH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, ACROSS THE PARTISAN
SPECTRUM.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO DR. FAUCI
TO TELL THE TRUTH.
THAT’S WHAT HE DID THIS WEEKEND.
I THINK THAT’S WHY HE’S IN THIS
POSITION, THAT’S WHY I’M GLAD HE
STILL IN HIS POSITION, BECAUSE
THAT’S WHAT SCIENTISTS AND
DOCTORS NEED TO DO.
I HAVE LONG AGO GIVEN UP TRYING
TO READ THE TEA LEAVES OF
DONALD TRUMP’S TWITTER, AND TRY
AND PARSE OUT FROM THAT WHAT
MIGHT COME POLICY WISE.
BUT I HATE THE FACT THAT HE
RETWEETED SOMEONE CALLING FOR
DR. FAUCI’S FIRING.
IF HE DID, IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID ANYTHING TO SIDELINE
DR. FAUCI, TO TRY AND MOVE HIM
OUT OF SUCH A PROMINENT ROLE, I
HOPE HE WOULD HEAR PUSHBACK FROM
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
BECAUSE DR. FAUCI HAS PLAYED
SUCH AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
HELPING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THIS CRISIS, HARRIS.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, THERE
SEEMS TO BE, MELISSA, BIPARTISAN
AGREEMENT ON WHAT MARIE HARF
JUST SAID.
I WILL TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER,
THOUGH.
THE PALACE INTRIGUE AND THE
FIGHTING, I JUST -- I DON’T KNOW
IF WE HAVE TIME FOR THAT.
[LAUGHS]
LIKE, AS A NATION, MELISSA.
>> Melissa: YES.
WE ABSOLUTELY DON’T.
ALTHOUGH, WHEN YOU SAY THAT HE
WENT OUT THIS WEEKEND AND TOLD
THE TRUTH, THE IMPLICATION IS
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
TELLING THE TRUTH.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S ACCURATE.
I THINK WITH THE PRESIDENT IS
REACTING TO IS THIS IDEA THAT HE
TAKES HIS RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE VERY PERSONALLY,
VERY SERIOUSLY.
SO I WOULD IMAGINE THAT, WHEN HE
FEELS LIKE SOMEONE IS ATTACKING
HIM, POTENTIALLY, FOR NOT DOING
HIS VERY BEST TO SAFEGUARD
AMERICA’S HEALTH AND WELFARE, HE
GETS VERY ANGRY.
THAT’S WHERE THOSE TWEETS COME
FROM.
HE JUST TAKES IT INCREDIBLY
PERSONALLY.
I AGREE WITH MARIE, I THINK
DR. FAUCI IS SOMEBODY WHO BOTH
SIDES REALLY TRUST, AND IT’S
ESSENTIAL THAT HE IS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION, AND THAT HE
CONTINUES IN HIS POST.
I THINK THAT ALL OF US, WE TAKE
COMFORT IN THE FACT THAT THESE
TWO DO DISAGREE, AND MOVE ON.
DR. FAUCI HAS SAID REPEATEDLY,
"THE PRESIDENT LISTENS TO ME
EVEN WHEN WE DISAGREE.
HE LISTENS TO ME AND WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
I HEAR HIM, HE HEARS ME."
SHE IS RIGHT, THAT IS ESSENTIAL
GOING FORWARD.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, GUY, I
LOOK AT THIS -- AND I WROTE DOWN
A NOTE TO MYSELF ABOUT WHEN I
WATCH PUBLIC PEOPLE FIGHT, AND
HOW USUALLY, AS MOST OF HIS
POINTING OUT, THE DEBATE
SOMETIMES CAN BE EDIFYING.
BECAUSE ONE PERSON HAS YOUR
POINT OF VIEW ON THE OTHER
DOESN’T, SO ON AND SO FORTH, AND
HOW THEY WORK IT OUT.
I THINK MELISSA IS RIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
IT’S PRETTY HEALING TO SEE THAT
GO FORTH.
AT LEAST YOU THINK IT’S NOT
ABOUT WHO IS RIGHT BUT WHAT IS
RIGHT.
WHICH IS ALWAYS MY GOAL.
I DO HAVE TO SAY, THOUGH, AT
TIMES, THE PUBLIC FIGHT IS NOT
HELPFUL.
WHEN IT’S JUST ABOUT THE
SNIPING.
READY BUT THIS?
>> Guy: WITH DR. FAUCI IN THIS
LITTLE FLAP INVOLVING THE
WEEKEND, WHEN YOU WATCH THE FULL
INTERVIEW HE DID ON ANOTHER
NETWORK THEY GOT SOME ATTENTION,
HE WAS IN SOME WAYS DEFENDING
THE PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE THERE WERE PEOPLE OUT
THERE, A CNN DOCTOR SAYING, "OH,
THEY SHOULD HAVE ACTED SOONER,
THEY WERE FAR TOO LATE TO DO
WHAT WAS NECESSARY."
DR. FAUCI CAME BACK AND SAID,
"ACTUALLY, IT’S NOT THAT SIMPLE
FOR THESE VARIOUS REASONS."
HE ENDED THE PRESIDENT ON THE
SAME PAGE HERE.
THERE IS A FRINGE OF PEOPLE,
IT’S DEEPLY RESPONSIBLE, WANT TO
SEE DR. FAUCI FIRED.
I THINK THAT IS REALLY A
TERRIBLE IDEA FOR THE COUNTRY.
EVEN IF YOU DISAGREE WITH WHAT
HE’S DONE, IF YOU THINK WE’VE
GONE TOO FAR, TO FIRE THIS MAN
WHO IS AN EMINENT EXPERT I THINK
WOULD BE A DISASTROUS MISTAKE.
THE THING THAT IS ALSO
BOTHERSOME TO ME, HARRIS, IS THE
DEGREE TO WHICH SOME IN THE
MEDIA SEEMED VERY INVESTED IN
THIS PALACE INTRIGUE PLOT LINE,
WHERE THEY SORT OF STOKE EVERY
MEMBER.
ALMOST LIKE THEY ARE TRYING TO
GOAD THE PRESIDENT INTO DOING
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE VERY BAD
FOR THE COUNTRY BUT COULD BE BAD
FOR HIM POLITICALLY.
THEY LOVE EXPRESSING CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THIS MIGHT HAPPEN.
IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE A PERVERSE
ROUTINE, AND I WISH THEY WOULD
KNOCK THAT OFF.
>> Harris: I ALMOST PUT IN
ANOTHER LANE, TOO.
YOU CAN HAVE THAT POINT OF VIEW
THAT IT’S POLITICAL, OR THIS
MIGHT EVEN BE WORSE.
IS IT PERSONAL?
ARE THEY LOOKING FOR THOSE
MOMENTS TO LIGHT UP THEMSELVES,
A MOMENT THAT ISN’T REALLY EVEN
FOCUS ON?
I DON’T KNOW, IT’S JUST A
QUESTION.
DR. NESHEIWAT, I WANT TO GO TO
YOU BEFORE WE GO TO A QUICK
BREAK JUST TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
THIS.
DR. FAUCI, I SPIT OUT A COUPLE
LINES ABOUT HIS RESUME.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS, WHAT DO
YOU MAKE OF THE GOING BACK AND
BACK-AND-FORTH?
>> Dr. Nesheiwat: ?
>> Dr. Nesheiwat: I HAVE SO
MUCH WAS PORK
RESPECT FOR DR. FAUCI.I WATCHED
YESTERDAY.
THAT NETWORK, THEY TWISTED HIS
WORDS.
HE DIDN’T SAY, "YES, WE SHOULD
HAVE DONE THIS."
HE SAID, ""COULDA, SHOULDA,
WOULDA."
OF COURSE IT COULD HAVE BEEN A
BETTER OUTCOME.
HE WAS GENERALIZING IN HIS
STATEMENT.
THEY TWISTED HIS WORDS.
HE WAS DOING ANYTHING IN HIS
POWER TO PROTECT AMERICANS.
THAT’S WHAT WE NEED.
>> Harris: INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW, FOR A WHILE, ABOUT
THIS TIME WE HAD BEEN HEARING
REGULARLY FROM GOVERNOR CUOMO.
ONE THING THAT HE SAID, GUY -- I
HEARD YOU SAY "MM-HMM AS
DR. NESHEIWAT WAS TALKING --
THAT THE TIME TO LOOK BACK IS
NOT THIS TIME.
HE SAID IT IN MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS.
HE SAID NO BLUE STATES, NO RED
STATES, JUST RED, WHITE, AND
BLUE.
A QUICK LAST THOUGHT AND WILL
MOVE ON.
>> Guy: THERE WILL BE LOTS OF
TIME FOR FINGER-POINTING, AND
IT’S ALREADY HERE IN SOME WAYS.
I THINK ULTIMATELY -- AND WE’LL
TALK ABOUT THIS LATER IN THE
PROGRAM -- THE RESULTS ARE GOING
TO BE WHAT MATTERS MOST.
A LOT OF THE PARTISAN FOOD
FIGHTING CURRENTLY HAPPENING, I
THINK IT’S PROBABLY A BIG
TURNOFF TO MOST PEOPLE WHO JUST